there are quite a few rotating buildings
in the world houses for people who want
their view to follow the sun maybe
they're built as an architect's dream
house maybe as an engineering challenge
or sometimes to give the best angles for
solar power over the years I have asked
to film in a few of those houses but
I've always been turned down they're
private homes but this one near San
Diego California is now on sale the real
estate agent got in touch and asked if I
wanted to have a look around to be clear
this is not an advert they're not paying
me but I just wasn't going to turn this
down because there are two things I want
to find out first of all how on Earth
does the plumbing work and second if
this is someone's dream house and it is
then why are they selling it my wife and
I decided we're going to build a house
it just so happened this lot went on the
market that same day we happened to see
the sign we bought it I'm trying to
figure out what to build I said you know
why not around house that way more rooms
will have more View and my wife said
fine then I thought some rooms still
have to look at the mountain
so I said why don't we rotate it to my
surprise she said fine I thought crap I
got to figure out how to do that so I
started to figure out how to actually
build something that would rotate so
every room would have every view yes of
course I asked if I could flip the
switch and control the rotation
foreign
good
it's very strange to push a button and
then have the world start to rotate
around you that's lovely my wife and I
started Construction in 2000
it took a good two years to get to the
point where we had a structure we did
hire some people and and had them
working here and I found that they would
go home at four o'clock and I would be
here till seven fixing what they had
done because they're used to building
square and this was round
the fella at San Diego County would go
over our plans and he says I just want
to tell you you're building something
that's way stronger than it needs to be
no way you can rotate that much mass and
have it work so I said do you care if it
rotates
he says hell I don't care if it rotates
and I said well then can we just agree
to disagree and you let me go ahead and
build the damn thing and he said all
right in doing all the calculations
I came up with needing a five horsepower
motor
so I put in a five horsepower motor
have you ever driven your car in fifth
gear at 25 miles an hour it goes like
that and that's how the house was moving
cut it down to a one and a half
horsepower motor that goes through a 25
to 1 reduction transmission through 71
to 1 Torque Hub that drives the two 16
inch in diameter Wheels we can turn the
house in 45 minutes you can go to bed to
the Sunset and wake up to the sunrise in
the same bed you have guests over during
dinner we'll turn the house so that
everybody at the dinner table gets to
see the sunset and a lot of rotating
buildings it's only part of the floor
that rotates the things that require
Plumbing like the kitchen and bathroom
don't move at all but here the sinks and
toilets and electrical sockets all
rotate as part of the house and all the
explanations I can find seem to hand
wave the details they just say that
there's a central non-rotating core that
handles the pipes for electricity there
are off-the-shelf components that can
deal with rotation there's a thing
called a slip ring which is a very
standard piece of equipment just like a
merry-go-round America round goes around
and around and around and doesn't have
to go back backwards same thing here it
happens to be a fancy one 16 brushes
that go around a copper piece about that
big and they ride on the copper and that
is your connection for telephone
internet there's also an off-the-shelf
component a Mercury slip ring a sealed
connector with a small pool of mercury
conductive liquid metal in the center
both sides can rotate they just stay
connected to the liquid but that's not
the difficult part I can understand
having one connection going through the
middle for water or Wastewater or gas
they can just sit on a central pipe and
swivel but how can you have all three
going through the same Central Hub the
topology doesn't work they can't all
occupy the exact center but if they're
offset then as the house rotates surely
the lengths of the pipes and cables has
to change or if they're slack surely
they'll get twisted it turns out owl has
a very clever solution to that obviously
you don't want to mix the gas the gray
water the sewer the drinking water so I
designed a slip ring for those Services
big piece of Steel about that big around
this is fixed
as we grooved it it's about a three inch
by three inch Groove all the way around
top Groove is sewer the next Groove is
gray water the next Groove is drinking
water the bottom Groove is gas and there
are holes drilled through this from the
sewer from the gray water and so forth
they're all separate holes that come out
the bottom
then there's a piece that comes down the
outside this piece rotates with the
house you have a sewer line that comes
down and connects to the outer piece
and then you have gray water then you
have drinking water then you have gas
there are seals in between each of these
grooves they're all alarmed there's a
seal a sensor ring and a seal a seal a
sensor ring and a seal so forth for all
of them you would have to have two seals
and two sensors fail before you add any
mixture of fluids the seals are good for
75 years so I I don't think we're going
to have a problem yes I had to
commission some graphics to explain this
it's really clever and I did not
understand it until Alex explained it to
me it's like four intersecting funnels
the total maintenance once a year is to
lube the bearings
we have a young man who has done it
several times it's done in an hour which
brings me to the other big question I
had after designing and constructing
this place after 20 years of living here
why sell it I've had 18 heart procedures
my wife is in perfect health
the odds of me outliving her are zero
she was born and raised in Coronado
we're moving back to Coronado because
this is a complex house even though I
think it's simple for her to try and
teach somebody else how to run
everything and do everything would be
difficult if something happened to me so
we're just kind of jumping ahead and
Coronado is a pretty nice place to go
will this place sell quickly I don't
know I'm not a real estate agent but I
certainly hope that there'll be people
who want to live somewhere with this
view in a home that's this different